all right
you should go ahead and get started yeah
so thanks a lot for coming back uh you
know our first talk of the afternoon is
going to be hypenglow who's going to
talk to us about
no regret learning in time-varying
zero-sum games then after that we're
gonna have eric talking as well um and
just one quick reminder is uh yeah if
you have open problems add them to the
sign up board for tomorrow it should be
a lot of fun with that i think i'll uh
hand it off to high pine
thank you
yeah so i'm gonna talk about um no
regret learning
in time varying zero sum games so this
is john to work with uh my student monk
xiao we are from ufc and uh two
collaborators from london university
peng and chihuahua
so i guess for this audience i don't
need to convince you that uncoupled
learning dynamics
for fixed game
is well study okay
so but what we started
to think about is
what if the game is changing over time
okay
so
um so in some cases uh these changes
they depend on um the the players
actions for that in which case you can
model this as a either markov game
extensive phone games etc okay so i will
take an example from every title stock
earlier in this program
um
so you mentioned packet traffic routing
over the internet and so in this case
the game is changing over time and
that's because um
there are uncertain package packets from
previous rounds and that is determined
to at least partially determined uh by
by the player's actions
okay so that's the force into this uh
case
and i want to argue that there are
also other cases where um the changes
only uh they're only caused by some
extortionist factors okay that they're
not
uh determined by the prayers actions
so if we look at uh this example just a
morning
our traffic
so um the the game can change over time
but the changes uh for example they come
from either the road construction or uh
some accidents okay so which has little
to do with the player's actions
so uh so in this talk i'm going to focus
on this second case so the changes are
caused by exogenous factors it turns out
that at least to our understanding is a
not very well studied supply assembly
so in particular i'm going to focus on
couple learning over a sequence of uh
time-varying two-player zero-sum normal
form games okay again uh they are
changing uh uh
exorcionously by the environment
so um so again and i'm focusing on the
the simplest case and normal form games
so no rl in this talk although i will
come back to this uh as a future
direction at the end
but even for this uh a simplest case it
turns out that uh how to measure the
performance uh requires some careful
thoughts okay so that's gonna be the
first part of this talk
i'm gonna in particular i'm going to
review a
existing measure i'm going to argue why
it is uh
problematic at least for some cases
and then i'm going to consider three
natural measures
one of them is proposed proposed by us
then in the second part of the talk i'm
going to move on to uh propose uh one
algorithm that we designed and uh this
is the parameter we are wisdom
and it achieves a strong guarantees
under all the three performance measures
that we consider
okay
simultaneously
and and importantly it also kind of
recovers the best known results when the
game is
fixed so that's kind of the
agenda for my talk
so let me now go into the setup um so
again we are considered considering this
repeated game setting
where for each round t of the game
um the environment first decides a
payoff matrix a t
okay so let's say the the payoffs are
all normalized between minus one uh to
one
and eighty depends on t so it's changing
over time
so without knowing the the playoff
matrix 18 x player designs a mixed
strategy xt
from the simplex over m actions okay and
simultaneously why prayer desires a
mixed strategy yt
from the simplex over and actions
so and then x player suffers loss
executions for atypi okay which is
standard and observed uh this
loss vector a t y t
and so in other words he can reason
about like what he would have suffered
uh if he
chose a different
mixed
strategy okay and similarly a y player
uh receive the same value but as the
reward and and see this vector x t
transpose 18. okay so this is sometimes
called the mixture feedback and it's
also kind of uh
well study
when 80 is fixed
okay so again when it is fixed this is
this very standard
repeated game learning setting
so and i hope i convince you that
there are cases where 80 is indeed
changing over time um
and and it's decided like associated by
the environment
and if you are not convinced yes they
are also kind of more
kind of implicit or theoretical
applications of this model uh for
example these two problems all nitrogen
lp and adversarial bandits with snapsec
they can all be modeled exactly as this
problem
okay
but i'm not going to go into the details
i hope the setup is clear
right
so i'm going to measure a few related
work so the the most related one is this
one by uh cardoso abanasi wang and shi
so they basically consider the exact
same problem except that their feedback
is either the entire matrix 80
which is stronger than us or just one
entry sampled from the the to the mixed
strategy
which is weaker than us okay
so i will come back to this work later
so another uh recent work is by a royal
door
they consider the more general
connection concave games but but their
performance measure is different which i
will also touch upon briefly later
and there are also other other works
that do say at all and also
fees a lot so they are less related they
do not exactly capture this problem
that i'm considering okay and i'm sure
there are more that i'm not listening
here
so okay now let me uh tell you how uh
let's start how to measure performance
in this setting
so the the
the most natural thing is still just to
minimize the classical regret so whether
the game is changing or not you can
still always define and and try to
minimize the individual regret okay so
uh which makes sense uh for each player
because they're just kind of selfishly
minimizing
um
uh the difference between their their
loss
and the loss of the best fixed action in
hindsight
okay
or a pacific strategy in high science
okay so that's the regret for x player
and again it's uh the
classical measure
and similarly for y prayer you can
define the same thing
so you can still do the entire
time varying game
but beyond this individual regret uh so
so we want to know what kind of other
games theoretic guarantees we can
argue about
so for example when the game is fixed
it's well known that we can argue about
the closeness of either the empirical
strategy or even the last iterate
to to the non-equilibrium of this fixed
game a
okay so that's again
well studied
and that's what i mean by game theoretic
guarantees and
um so now the question is when at is
changing over time then obviously you
don't have a fixed set of uh
nash and then what what kind of similar
guarantees you can argue about
so that's the
the question
and so so one proposal uh proposal here
is something called a nash equilibrium
regret uh proposed by uh um cardoso at
all
so they
they consider the difference between
the actual value received by the players
and the minimax value of the cumulative
game with the sum of a sum of 80.
and the proposal now isn't that always
guaranteed sublinear uh bounce on this
any regret
okay so while this uh looks reasonable
at first glance and i'm gonna argue that
it has
like two important issues
so the first issue is that it's actually
incompatible with the classical regret
that i talked about at the beginning
okay so
this i mean this is actually already pro
proven in in their work they show that
no allison
can achieve a sublinear bounds for both
the classical regret and any regret
simultaneously
so in other words if you want to always
have sublime request on this any regret
then there exists a sequence of games
such that your individual regret is
linear which is very vacuous
okay so that's what i mean by uh
any regret is incompatible with
classical regret
and that's kind of bad because again i
think it's very natural to
try to uh for each person try to kind of
selfishly minimize the classical regret
okay so that's the first issue
and then uh the second issue is that uh
we show that this any regret can in fact
be linear in t
even for perfect prayers so here by
perfect prayers i mean players that
always are played not in each round
okay
so to see this uh just consider very
simple example let's say for the first
half of the rounds you're just playing
this game which is just uh matching
pennies
and then for the rest you play this kind
of boring uh game
there's just two different games
and so it's easy to say that to see that
um so let's say we consider two players
always play the notch each time
then for the
first half of the rounds
then the the value is just zero okay
everything's symmetric here so the value
is zero
and for the second half the value is
going to be one because in the
in the nash the white player is going to
always pick the first column
and then no matter what the x player
plays the uh the the the reward the loss
is one
so that's why the cumulative uh value
this part is t over two okay
and if you look at the cumulative gamm
which is this okay
it's easy to see that the value is just
zero okay x place always pick the second
row okay so this part is just zero
okay so in the end uh the last uh the
the any regret uh for
this uh uh this perfect player turns out
to be a linear and t
okay
so that's why we think this measure is
uh
problematic in this sense
exactly
okay good
um so it's kind of inspired by this
issue uh we if we propose a new measure
that's similar
yeah go ahead
word from this one and what we propose
is to kind of move the min max inside
the sum
okay so it means that we are comparing
the uh
the value at each time and the minimum
minimax value of
the game for that round
okay and we're looking at this
cumulative difference
okay
yeah so another question i'd like to ask
is yeah
somehow obvious from the exam that you
need a dynamic nas equilibrium regret
but
do we have a budget about how much the
games can change yes
that's a very good question yes in the
end we're gonna measure the difficulty
uh in terms of the health and
downstation view of the camera juice and
i will talk about this uh very soon okay
all right um okay so so again dynamic
any request would be proposed and and so
the connection between these
dynamics is kind of just
at least on the surface analogous to the
connection between classical regret and
its dynamic version okay so this is the
classical regret where you compete with
the fixed action in hindsight and the
well-known dynamic version
of this is just to move the mean inside
okay so you're competing with the best
sequence of actions it's the best action
at each time
okay this is also
well standing and again our connection
between these two is similar to this
okay
yes
so
the dynamical light seems like extremely
harder than the standard regret
yes
for the classic photography yes we're in
the screen setting the synthesis the
case is that the exactly my next one so
for cars it was less always smaller than
dynamic uh regret but uh that's not true
for any immigrant so dynamic any web
could be smaller than
any other plant okay so so to see that
just consider the again the perfect
prayers again so if they always play the
notch then dynamic request obviously
just
zero
okay while in the example i'll show you
last in the last line you see that any
of the word is
this one in this case
okay
so so that's why
they're kind of now this is only on the
surface
and uh
and more importantly a dynamic regret
it's also compatible with classical
regret
as we will see so in other words you can
obtain
meaningful guarantees for both of them
simultaneously
that's why
to us it makes more sense to consider
dynamic any regret other than any
immigrant
but you're just considering something
different yes
okay good
all right so uh the last thing i want to
talk about in terms of measuring
so approaching the the minimax value of
the game doesn't really mean you're uh
close like at least in the traditional
traditional sense of being close to the
natural equilibrium
so instead if you really want to measure
the closeness to the notch you can look
at let's say the duality gap okay so
this part is just the duality gap of the
strategy x t and y t to the game with
respect to game a t
okay and i'm just summing up all these
duality gaps yes
some natural situations
[Music]
because usually it maybe changes slowly
or if the graph changes right right
but but in that case
it will be
good also right if you if the change is
small the amount of changes is more then
you will get a favorable teeth for these
dynamics
but let's say the matrix changes ten
times yes then what will happen can you
say what happened yeah we will get a
constant for this dynamic and we can
right
okay so duality gets another natural one
and i mean you know so there are of
course other possibilities you can also
also uh consider let's say the exact the
let's say the hour distance between fcyd
to the set of uh
and but in this case
the bound usually depends on some
problem specific constant other than
this the size of the the matrix okay
which is uh less appearing to us so
that's why we we're not considering that
in this work
so just to quickly uh uh summarize we
are considering d3 measure and this work
the individual regret the classical one
dynamic any regret which is what we
proposed and also the natural draw
together
okay
and a quick remark is that you can in
fact show that the first two is always
bounded by the last one so to also give
is always the large largest one and but
this upper bound is can be quite loose
so so it doesn't means that you can
you just need to care about duality gap
because you can
in some cases get a much better bounce
on the first two measures
and now let me get to uh this uh
notion of non-stationary that several of
you have already mentioned so so it's
very easy to see that no meaningful
guarantees can be obtained for the last
two measures if the game just changes
arbitrarily okay
so you need some notion of uh to do to
capture the difficulty of the problem so
in in other words you need some notion
of non-stationarity of the the the
payoff sequences
and and so here we consider three so the
first two are the kind of the variation
of this 18 sequence and also kind of the
variance of the sequence so a a bar is
the average
of the the games
okay
and another one is you can also measure
the variation in terms of the nash okay
so this is the variation of the the
sequence of uh
nash and let's say if the if you have
multiple uh nash just consider the
sequence that minimize minimizes this
quantity okay
so these are three and kind of
non-stationarity measures we consider so
in the worst case they they can all be
like of order t
and but they could be uh as long as it's
not in the worst case uh
um uh you you can hope to get something
um good
and just again a quick remark uh vt is
kind of always bounded by wt up to some
constant and and but they are
incompatible with pt january so you can
come up with example where uh one is
constant the other is linear and and
vice versa
okay
and finally uh let me just say again
that the goal now is that whenever
you're not in the worst case so whenever
these non-stationary measures or at
least some of them are sabrina and t you
hope to obtain a subliminal bounds for
let's say dynamic regret and the duality
gap
so that's kind of critical
right
so if that's clear let me
go to the second part
uh on our awesome guarantees
so uh again we propose uh one uh
parameter three hours
that obtains the following guarantees
simultaneously so when deployed by both
players
so for individual regrets we obtain
something like a square root of qt where
qt is uh kind of like this so the
variation of the game plus the minimum
of the variation of the nash and the
variance of the game
okay so the important thing is that it's
always uh bounded by root t because q t
can most be t
and and in particular where uh if the
game turns out to be fixed then qt is
just zero and you get just uh oh due to
one regret so i'm hiding some uh log t
factors here
and
and this recovers the the best with
zombie shield
and similarly for dynamic regret you get
something uh again in terms of all the
non-stationary measure so it's gonna be
sublinear as soon as uh one of pt or wt
is sublinear
okay
and and again when uh when you are in
the uh fixed game scenario you you get
all q21
okay so again it recovers this work
and finally for duality cam because
something uh even more complicated but
again it's sabrina as soon as qts
sabrina
and when the game is fixed you get rooty
which recovers the best result from
work for my group last year
and um
yeah so that's it that's kind of a
result and and so as a lot mentioned uh
the last column actually also holds um
when let's say 80 changes constant times
okay so because in this case
all these measures are just constant i
mean acceptability okay but but if you
plug in uh the result you can you can
see that uh indeed you can get all these
bonds even if
the game change changes for constant
times
okay
the last remark is that uh the the
individual regret uh you can also have
some robustness guarantee so if only x
player uh uses our always them and why
player kind of deviates from uh this
alison so that's why period behaves
arbitrarily you can still get routine
regret for the experience yes
but the comparator is the mean
which can be worse than just
the best strategy in hindsight for that
particular
fixed matrix
but it's midnight for each round
right let's say you have a bunch of
thousands
right yes
it's not as good it's just the best
let's say there's no change in the
matrix then it doesn't matter one round
of minimum right
but minmax is not as good as just start
up the grip because
yes uh right
right
it's
yes yes we i mean in the end
yes it has some productivity
okay
yes is there any sense about auction
value of that kind of results it's like
registered peers
and he also suspected especially for
geology campus uh not times because
if you can see the the
exploring here do not add up to one so
everybody we're seeing like this uh
comparable but kiki are not comparable
so yes
do you have results like bose ptn
or vtr necessary
that's a good question no we haven't
thought about that
okay
so okay so let me
talk about a little bit about the hours
and design
so
uh let's review what happened in the
fixed game setting so for this game um
so this works recurrence at all they
propose uh this is the rvu property that
says that uh
if your regret can be bounded by let's
say the variation in the utility vectors
so ayt or
it's basically the negative utility for
x player and this is just a variation in
the utility for x player so you want
your regret to be bounded by this
quantity
and also what the name doesn't suggest
is
but it's as important as the this
negative term in terms of the variation
of this makes the strategy of x player
okay if you have an alison that satisfy
this uh we call it a satisfied rvu
property
and here eta is an earning rate of the
parameter of the algorithm and alpha
beta gamma there's just some constant
that you don't need to care about
okay so so first this is satisfied by
many so-called optimistic online
learning algorithms such as optimistic
hatch and optimistic gradient descent
that i'm not going to talk about in
details
but the but this is useful because if
you look at the blue term the variation
is actually bounded by the the variation
of the y players strategy
okay and then if you compare these two
red terms they are basically symmetric
so meaning that if you for example sum
up these the regress of x pre and y
player they basically cancel
okay so you don't have this this second
and third term anymore so your request
is going to be very small
so and it has a lot of a nice
implication then
okay so that's what happened for a fixed
scan
and then uh for time varying games which
is our setting uh it turns out that it's
important to again consider uh um
competing with a sequence of uh
time-varying strategy let's go u1 u2 up
to ut
and and then we
very naturally we propose this dynamic
rvu property it says that we want our
regret competing with this ut sequence
we bounded by basically the same thing
except 80 is now changing
and also the the first term one over
eighteen now depends on uh this ptu
which is the variation of the comparator
sequence u
okay
so it's a very natural generation and
importantly it's also satisfied by stand
they are wisdom so for example satisfied
directory by optimistic gradient descent
which is written here so don't worry
about it if you don't know what it is
and and it also satisfied by optimistic
hatch if you do it over a truncated
simplex okay
so that's that and
the thing is that
for each performance performance measure
that we consider
this property is the rvu property in
fact implies some guarantees already
okay so it requires some non-trivial
analysis especially for the duality gap
but but it's enough okay so the view is
enough
but the the thing is that the catch is
that uh to do so each measure requires a
different turning of the the learning
rate data
okay and also the knowledge of the
non-stationarity the vtw tnpt
okay so that's why uh
this is not enough
and and to achieve all these guarantees
simultaneously and also without knowing
the uh the non-stationarity
what we propose is just to kind of
maintain a set of
base algorithms each with this property
with some different tunings of eta
and then on top of this
we
have another optimistic meta algorithm
to learn over this set of base
algorithms
okay
so this is of course
also a standard idea so just learning
the learning rate framework is kind of
standard and but the right execution
here requires some new ideas two new
ideas in particular and and in terms of
analysis you also need to carefully
control the overhead of the material
wisdom
okay how much more time do i have
okay
okay so so let me then let me just show
you the always overview then i guess i'm
done then
um so again your input is just any basic
algorithm that's satisfied drvu and i
already give you two examples
so and then the the method also
maintains a set of log t based learners
so each uh satisfy a the drv property
again with a certain uh eta from an
exponential grid
so uh now each time t you first collect
the strategy outputs by each baseline
then you come up with some prediction
vector empty uh that i'm not going to
talk about
and and then you update a distribution
pd over the base learners okay according
to this kind of
gradient descender
procedure okay
then your final action is just the
mixture of the the output of the
baseline according to pt okay
so then you you suffer the last you
upset this vector and you send it to
each base learner so they can do their
updates
and finally you you come up with some
loss vector and update this kind of
auxiliary sequence ppt hat okay which is
used in computing pt
okay so so in in other words metal
analysis is in fact also just doing
matter so it's doing optimistic uh
gradient descent but over this space
okay the distribution over the
base learners
okay but the two new ideas is first
it turns out that this is not enough you
also need a set of kind of dummy learner
to always select a fixed action okay so
intuitively this allows them the
the metahousing to be directly
comparable to the natural at each time
okay you can find pt
with this dummy learner you can find pt
so that this mixture is exactly the nash
so and this turns out to be important
for the analysis
and second in terms of how to design
this mt and dlt it turns out that you
need to add some bias towards more
stable us you cannot just do the most
natural thing
okay
i don't have time to go and do this so
let me skip all these
okay we did some experiments not gonna
talk about that
okay so to summarize the takeaway is
that um
for a sequence of time varying games um
it's actually requires more thought uh
on how to measure the performance of a
learning algorithm okay so we uh we
provide some measures but by no means
they are the best okay
and so but another thing is another
message is that simultaneously strong
guarantees under different measure is
possible okay as we show in this work
finally let me conclude with some open
questions so the first one is kind of
most related to this setup so what the
feedback model we have considered is
this sort of full information
mixture feedback where you see this map
for x player
so of course you can consider that like
the banded version or even the kind of
the fully uh realization based feedback
so we which are much harder
and many techniques in this work
actually fail unfortunately okay so we
don't really know what to do
second direction is to consider kind of
general some games
and finally to record it at the
beginning is that the changes from
time-varying games can depend on
either the players action or by the
environment okay but in fact you can
also have changes coming from both
okay so that's kind of like for example
you can model it as a time varying
markov games okay which i don't think we
know much about
okay so these are the three directions
that i think are interesting so that
concludes my talk thanks
thanks a lot
uh yeah in the interest of time why
don't we maybe take like one question
and then uh maybe hai pan can uh answer
any other questions offline
a lot yeah let me give you the mic
thank you uh yeah thanks hyphen it's
very interesting so i
when do you think it is a better idea
to look at min max as opposed to just
regret like in a when do you think this
can be a good idea
because in a static game
i think regret kind of says this is not
a good idea so i wonder like in
you know i i don't think it's a good
idea to only look at one of these
measures but that's why we consider
several measures simultaneously right we
also have regret guarantee we are not
just just competing with uh minimax
values
but for minimax that's the main i guess
that's the main new thing the min max
values
but again
well just one the main measure we
propose but again i'll in the end i'll
always achieve guarantees for several
measures simultaneously and that's the
more difficult part
all right thanks a lot let's give high
five another
round of applause